but first the new counterculture that's
the focus of tonight's angle
entertainment elites are in total
freakout mode why because one of its
mega stars Kanye West announced that
he's thinking for himself it kind of
felt like a cultural earthquake over the
weekend when West tweeted that he liked
the way a conservative black activist
thought and yesterday followed this up
with a string of pro Trump tweets that
has the internet exploding he declared
his love for Trump and extolled the
dragon energy they share what is that
and he refused to let the mob shake his
love for the president hmm now look this
isn't about celebrating one superstars
endorsement of Donald Trump what I'm
gonna be talking about is shining a
light I'm the most intolerant crowd out
there you know the people who claim that
they have a monopoly on tolerance and
inclusion think about this other than
academia there really are few industries
that America the American Left dominates
like it does entertainment for Kanye's
sin of speaking his mind musical icons
like Drake Kendrick Lamar Nicki Minaj
and Rihanna unfollowed him on social
media what a punishment and the reaction
from elsewhere on the left was just as
pronounced different celebrities
desperate for attention and finding ways
whether it's positive or negative to get
it now his wife is tweeting back at
people basically saying don't be too
hard on my husband don't necessarily
make it seem like he's going through
some sort of mental breakdown which we
know he's had mental health problems I
don't even know what happened here
I think Kanye West just realized he's
too rich to not be Republican I don't
even know what it is we have the right
to independent thoughts and I
independently think that Kanye has lost
his mind it's Stephen still in character
I always forget look original thought
will not be tolerated by this crowd and
anyone who breaks from the Borg mindset
must be shunned or bullied back into the
fall
old Kanye shared a text exchange with
R&B superstar John Legend love John
Legend loved his music but this text
exchange today illustrates the point I'm
making legend writes I hope you
reconsider aligning yourself with Trump
you're way too powerful and influential
to endorse who he is and what he stands
for so many people who love you feel
betrayed right now because they know the
harm that Trump's policies cause
especially for people of color don't let
this be part of your legacy
well Kanye West wasn't impressed he
responded I love you John but bringing
up my fans and my legacy is a tactic
based on fear used to manipulate my free
thought he's right I can't believe I'm
saying on my show Kanye West is right
he's right about this anyone who dares
to question the ideological orthodoxy of
the left particularly a black artist
must be brought back into line now let's
talk Turkey here whether Kanye West is
brilliantly punking today censorious
elites or whether he's sincerely
expressing a belief about the president
it's almost immaterial Kanye West I
think has cracked open the door on the
glaring hypocrisy of the left now they
claim to defend minority rights until a
minority disagrees with them they claim
to be for diversity until they truly
diverse viewpoint is heard what West
might have unwittingly done is made it a
little easier for others to stand up
against this herd mentality he did
receive some support for his
independence chance the rapper he's on
my playlist hardly a conservative voice
tweeted this black people don't have to
be Democrats
can't believe it's so scandalous now I
don't for a moment think that Kanye West
is a second to Tocqueville or the new
MLK all right I have vivid memories of
him at I was at some televised
fundraiser in the wake of Hurricane
Katrina George Bush doesn't care about
black people
nice and I can also remember when he
rudely rushed the stage to try to take a
music award from Taylor Swift that also
wasn't nice 15 years ago yes 15 years
ago I can't Harlow I can hardly believe
it I wrote a book called shut up and
sing which was in part a critique of the
political activism of all these high
paid celebrities like the Dixie Chicks
Barbra Streisand Jackson Browne list
went on and on the upshot is we pay them
to entertain we don't want to be captive
to their political ponderings someone
who for some ungodly reason does get
paid to pontificate on politics her name
is Miz Anna Navarro tweeted at me today
the following she said has miss Ingram
told Kanye to shut up and sing yet or
does that only apply to anti-trump black
celebrities I'll make it clear to you
Anna it applies to anyone peddling
political nonsense while lacking the
credentials or experience to do so Anna
well I'm not about to cheer the
political pronouncements of Kanye West
just because he's saying something nice
about Trump now the political musings of
uninformed celebrities frankly isn't of
much interest to me at all but I'll tell
you what is interesting to me the
over-the-top reaction to a big star
saying something truly countercultural
today that's of great interest to me
watching the left attack M for daring to
break ranks of them even in the vaguest
of terms talking about love and loving
people that is truly revealing what
Kanye West says or does in the days
ahead it's less important than the
conversation he started and who would
have thought that a bad boy like Kim
Kardashian's husband could be the
catalyst for an honest discussion about
the course conformity of thought that
the celebrity culture has imposed on all
of us and that's the angle